all right a new report from a Veterans
Affairs watchdog slams the department's
leadership the report blames failed
leadership and a climate of complacency
for putting patients at risk in a major
Washington Hospital current VA secretary
David Shulkin was the agency's
undersecretary for health at the time
and Jan Crawford is outside the VA
Medical Center in Washington with more
on this troubling report Jam good
morning well good morning the report
says that people at the VA under Shilka
knew about the safety issues here but
Shulkin says he does not recall hearing
about the problems this to me represents
a failure of the VA system at every
level Veterans Affairs Secretary David
Shulkin says he only learned of the
systemic issues at the Washington DC VA
hospital about a year ago when an
interim report revealed problems with
sterile equipment and unused inventory
the full report released Wednesday
revealed staggering deficiencies
patients who underwent prolonged
anesthesia because surgical instruments
were unavailable once they were put
under doctors and nurses forced to make
do by borrowing supplies from a nearby
hospital while 500,000 items set unused
in a warehouse and the government
renting items like three home hospital
beds for nearly eight hundred and
seventy-five thousand dollars that would
have caused only twenty one thousand
dollars to buy I think it was a failure
of leadership here Inspector General
Michael missile says while no patient
died as a result of the safety issues
patients were put at risk and senior
leaders didn't take responsibility
before the problems got worse we talked
to everybody and everybody pointed their
finger elsewhere
yesterday secretary Shulkin announced
changes to senior leadership at nearly
two dozen hospitals across the country
he also says the VA has appointed 24 new
facility directors at low performing
hospitals over the last year the DC VA
Medical Center has come a long way
American Legion executive director Verna
Jones is treated at the hospital herself
and has met with Shulkin she said the
report is quote concerning but the VA is
improving I believe that now things are
getting better and that dr. Shelton and
his team are addressing the root of the
problem in
we Ashokan why it's taken so long to
address problems at the VA we're not
declaring the problems of the VA over we
have a lot of work to do
now while shukla has been under fire
lately the White House said that he is
doing a great job and they're proud of
what they called his aggressive approach
John Jan thanks